[Musique]
madiran film porté par le collège
emilien adam de villiers à saint pierre
est le grand vainqueur de la troisième
saison du concours départemental du film
scolaire les treize collèges
participants sont partis sur les
sentiers de notre île le thème imposé
cette année l'objectif est atteint
inciter les collégiens à passer du rôle
de spectateur à celui de créateur bien
ce genre de projet ne peut que leur
faire du bien
recréer une cohésion de groupe donné
envie de continuer à voir aussi
cette ambition de dieu et d'aller plus
loin
peut-être certains d'entre eux ont
découvert un futur métier
peut-être qu'ils que ça leur donne aussi
du sens à ce qu'ils font au collège pour
tous à département continuera dans cette
danse est lancé chacun à leur tour les
collégiens ont pu parler de leurs
expériences et rappeler l'enrichissement
apportée par la réalisation de leur film
on est euphorique on est on a mis on a
mis beaucoup beaucoup de coeur dans ce
projet et le fait gagner on tremble
encore et on est tous heureux on a été
comme une famille quand toulon ce
tournage il ya eu des hauts des vagues
mais même les bat on était tous ensemble
et le tournage s'est très très bien
passé on l'a eue du matériel qu'on a
acheté professionnel c'est surtout les
élèves qui ont tourné il ya eu des
cameramans des acteurs les réalisateurs
s'étaient que des élèves on a eu
l'encadrement de laurent bouvier et de
monsieur bigot qui nous ont aidés et
tourner un petit peu dans le film et on
a tourné deux jours au dimitile on a
dormi dans le gîte au dimitile
on a fait beaucoup de marche et tout
s'est bien passé les films ont été
examinés par un jury composé de
représentants de la collectivité des
spécialistes de l'éducation nationale et
de professionnels du cinéma et de
l'audiovisuel
[Musique]